hi there Steve Kaufman here again again
you're gonna hear my wife working on her
scales she's so excited she downloads
these things from the internet I mean
she wouldn't go to a teacher but she can
find stuff on the internet that's really
helping her and she plays hours a day
and she's just loving it so we have that
as background music to our videos here
so to continue in the series about how I
went about learning languages I think
I'm gonna try to combine French and
Spanish because they both kind of came
at me at the same time in my life and
they were really quite instrumental to
the whole issue of me getting involved
with language learning so here I was in
Montreal Montreal in the 1950s was what
they called the two solitudes you had a
million english-speaking people and two
million french-speaking people and the
Inc you know the workplace was English
in the stores everything was English so
you as an english-speaking person
growing up in Montreal it was really not
very different from living in Toronto or
Chicago insofar as languages were
concerned and of course we had French in
school starting in grade two and we had
the sixteen verbs that take at and it
was like we were he studied it to pass
the exam and I did well I mean I did
fairly well at school and I did just as
well in French as I did in the other
subjects and I wasn't that interested I
went to McGill University in Montreal
and we had a professor mo he's a botana
was his name and he was just excellent
excellent because he made French
civilization French culture
interesting everything they did in
school made it uninteresting
whereas he weathered was him or the
environment of being at university or
the textbook and I still remember it had
these lovely pictures of of you know
paintings you know by Votto or whoever
it was of the different you know eras of
French culture and civilization
that we were studying but all of a
sudden it became interesting and and at
that same time I became interested in
the sort of movies of the Nouvelle Vague
I think it was called you know can't
remember the actresses in those days but
once you know as a teacher you have only
one job is to turn on the student easier
said than done once the student is
turned on you don't need the teacher and
so I not only enjoyed what I was
studying in class and we had to read
different books and it was just
fascinating discovering Voltaire and
Rousseau and and man oh let's go you
know and all the books and I like
traditional literature I have to say you
know about Jacques and so forth and and
then I started reading a local newspaper
la voie and of course in in Quebec at
that time it was at the time when all of
this the fervor the Fermin
you know where the Quebec wanted to be
met for chez nous because the economy
was controlled by the English and even
though the the the Quebec I mean they
were the largest group they controlled
the provincial politics but it was
corrupt it was you know the church had a
tremendous influence Quebec was the only
province in Canada that didn't have a
provincial Ministry of Education they
let the church run the education so they
had lots of notaries and and I don't
know priests and so this was all changed
by this sort of The Young Turks Jean
Lesage and of course Pierre to tweed all
was part of that group although he ended
up being more interested in federal in
federal politics
Hani Levesque who was eventually the the
leader of the separatist that all this
stuff is going on so it was very
interesting to read about it in the
newspaper and go and see French theater
even if I didn't understand it it was my
French period so I got totally into it
and and as I say once you're motivated
it's it's easy enough to learn and I
ended up going to France where I lived
for three years and I described
in the other video how I found work on a
on a German freighter going across to
Europe than I hitchhiked all over Europe
that summer and ended up in on habla
their oboe and eventually moved over to
political science and then I went for
two years to Paris to the 92 de toutes
politique and got my diploma there and I
had three wonderful years in France as a
student that lived in Paris I had a
bicycle I lived on the fifth floor of a
building that was built in 1789 the
bathroom was a bathroom but the toilet
was on the third floor
I had a big basin that I would fill with
water like I bought it I'm big aluminum
tub that I would sit in to wash myself
you know cold in the winter and ah but
fantastic so I had a great time and that
obviously it was very good for my French
because everything I had to do I had to
do in French so and that convinced me
that I could transform myself into
someone that could comfortably speak
another language because until you've
done that you don't believe you can do
it and part of the problem language
learners have is they can't really
visualize themselves fluently speaking
in other language so it's like climbing
a mountain where a you can't you don't
know where the peak is and you don't
think you can reach the peak and that's
a major problem that many language
learners have who have never ever
learned a second language so French was
a big deal for me now insofar as Spanish
I had a course at McGill in Spanish I
was one of those sort of electives that
I took one year and fortunately the
professor they got us right into reading
stories right away that's what we did we
didn't spend our time in class role
playing and talking to each other and
playing games and making you know
slideshows and all the stuff that they
seem to do now we just here's a book has
a glossary read it and I remember it was
you know there was
what the name of these stories were but
they took place in Balenciaga they took
place in wherever it took place and we
read them and accumulated vocabulary and
it was painstaking but there that was a
course and I passed it but I got
interested in Spanish and there were a
lot of you know people who had fought on
the Republican side in the Spanish Civil
War who lived in Montreal and there was
a cafe called de las elecciones paniolo
and they sat there playing dominoes and
I'd wander in there you know and I
thought I was a really cool guy 18 years
old and I'd order you know a drink and
watch all these Spanish guys play Domino
and hear them swearing in Spanish and
stuffing and but then when I arrived in
France
I used to hitchhike every holiday every
chance I get and the favorite
destination was Spain so I go into what
was then Franco's Spain and I'll tell
you that people were I mean I'll explain
today but his pain in those days was
unbelievable you people were so friendly
you know foreigners were a rarity the
first night I arrived in Barcelona I was
on a bus going out to the youth hostel
and people I started talking to people
and the bumbling in my Spanish come to
the bar and drink and you sit around and
you're pouring wine out of this
container that has a great big spout and
whatever so I would hitchhike a lot in
Spain and hours and hours and hours of
sitting with truck drivers and other
people who picked me up gave me a lot of
chance to speak Spanish so I I kind of
had that and with the French vocabulary
and even coming from English a lot of
the words are of Latin origin but so I
had this sort of bumbling acquaintance
with Spanish but going to Spain in more
recent years I decided that really you
know really try to improve it and I
always think that in any when you're
learning any language a major point is
when you have read your first book and
I'm not talking about reading like on
the computer with online dictionaries I
mean you're reading it ignoring the
words you don't know and reading it
and the first book that I read was
called in Spanish and I read it maybe
six seven years ago
it's called el bosque he mocking in
Bosque origin REO by horn what is to who
I believe his bath I'm not sure but he
writes about you know all the myths of
origin of different people's in Europe
and it's a subject that fascinates me
because I like that subject you know I
like this whole idea of people with
their myths of origin I believe a lot of
this sort of identity and ethnic
identity is largely imaginary and it's
largely elective and you can choose to
to belong to whoever in whichever group
you want to belong to so that it was a
fascinating book and so if you are
interested in the subject then you can
read you can read through it I remember
going back to German the first book that
I really read from cover to cover in
German was written by the former
president their white sector and it was
about the environment I read it on a
plane eight hours on a plane is a great
place to read by the way you got nothing
else to do no one to bother you so and
then subsequent to that I just happen to
look through my library here a book that
I really enjoyed was la sombra del
viento by carlos ruiz it's a phone
because I spent so much time in
Barcelona when I was hitchhiking and a
wonderful time there I'd buy a Spanish
guitar I'd buy my two bottles of
fundador cheap brandy which right I
would keep in my room in Paris
so yeah reading and then you know I wish
I could do more to improve my Spanish I
just haven't had time I have done a
couple of the audiobooks at link
political dose I think one was I can't
remember but they all they're historical
novels they're very very nice and we
have the LibriVox versions at links so
I've gone through trying to upgrade my
vocabulary and listen listen listen
also when I was in Spain again four five
years ago I discovered this group Orissa
of the cope a radio station who are very
funny Copa happens to be on the right
wing you know Catholic conservative side
of things but I'm always interested in
the language basically and and they're
quite funny so yeah
you know again French has been a big
part of my life because I spent those
three years there I love going there but
I mean I like everywhere that I go I
mean I Japan where we lived for nine
years we always heard nostalgic wherever
wherever you've been and learnt the
languages it's great fun as is as is the
case with Spain I'm trying to remember
if there's anything else with regard to
Spanish yeah you know I keep emphasizing
this reading thing now some people don't
like to read they like to watch TV fine
you got to do what you like I think and
and I always emphasize that and in
language learning you gotta like the
language you gotta like what you're
doing you got to put in the time but but
reading in terms of building up your
vocabulary is it's just it's the most
effective way of building up your
vocabulary and then when you are
confronted with the need as was the case
with me in Spain to speak you know it
slowly slowly slowly the words start to
come out and you hear them and you
relate to what you read and and so you
build up your vocabulary and if you have
a vocabulary I believe you will and if
you're attentive to the language and try
to listen to how things are pronounced
you will learn to speak so the biggest I
and as I've said many times it's the
same with literacy in your own language
reading is key I look at my
grandchildren and and if they're reading
a lot which they are I'm happy because
whatever else happens in their
schoolwork if they if they read well
they'll do fine and and the same is true
in language learning so I kind of did
French and Spanish together because I
didn't have that much original say about
them and I will try to get into we've
had people asked me for Portuguese
Russian and maybe check why did I bother
with check um so there you have it thank
you for listening bye for now